foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing the Wizarding afterlife
taking a closer look at what exactly
happens to witches and wizards when they
die the line between the living and the
dead is unquestionably a blurry one in
Harry Potter this is reinforced by the
prevalence of beings that skirt these
two planes of existence ghosts and
Dementors are some of the first that
come to mind and with these Blurred
Lines the topic of death which is also a
key thematic element in Harry Potter
becomes even more alluring in fact one
of the main messages of the Harry Potter
books is that death is not absolute it's
also reinforced that it's not anything
we should be worrying about we're
continually reminded that death is
simply a part of life and that rather
than obsessing over it we should instead
shift our focus on seeking love and
friendship enjoying the time that we do
have Voldemort infamously tried to evade
dead
which is why his name is aptly derived
from the French Voldemort meaning flight
of death but the lesson the books teach
surrounding the inevitability of death
is one that never quite resonated with
our immortality obsessed antagonist
rather than Embrace Life at its own pace
Voldemort devised all sorts of plans to
achieve the ever elusive goal of
immortality on a side note there are
actually five methods of achieving
immortality in Harry Potter if you're
curious about them check out my video
all five methods of immortality in Harry
Potter so life and death have Blurred
Lines but what exactly does that mean
what happens to a witch or wizard when
they die why do some become ghosts is
there an afterlife the soul the first
thing we need to focus on is the
existence of the soul that is the life
force by which corporeal and incorporeal
form can be distinguished the existence
of a soul is a somewhat abs abstract
concept which means it's hard to Define
however the generally accepted concept
of a soul is that it's a kind of
immaterial spiritual Essence an
actuating cause of an individual's life
it's what makes us tick and it certainly
has no scientific explanation it's the
soul that Dementors feed on its pieces
of soul that Voldemort imparts into
objects and it's the soul that Avada
Kedavra purportedly rips out of the body
the soul is what keeps our corporeal
form Earthbound and that's why it plays
a significant role in the conversation
surrounding the Wizarding afterlife
you can exist without your soul you know
as long as your brain and heart are
still working but you'll have no sense
of self anymore no memory no anything
there's no chance at all of recovery
you'll just exist as an empty shell and
your soul is gone forever last Harry
Potter very much perpetuates the idea
that ultimately the physical body is
merely a shell a vessel that merely
transports the vital life force within
and because the soul is immaterial it
exists forever it's also reinforced that
unless you live a particularly cursed
existence like Voldemort then the Soul
won't be affected by death and the
subsequent exit from The Immortal Realm
look if I picked up a sword right now
Ron and ran you through with it I
wouldn't damage your soul at all which
would be a real Comfort to me I'm sure
said Ron Harry laughed it should be
actually but my point is that whatever
happens to your body your soul will
survive
untouched said Hermione in fact it seems
as though in most cases quite the
opposite happens with the soul becoming
vitalized or purified and reverting the
individual back to their Prime State
this is reinforced through Harry's
interaction with the souls of his loved
ones in the Forbidden Forest Sirius was
tall and handsome and younger by far
than Harry had seen him in life he loped
with an easy Grace his hands in his
pockets and a grin on his face Lupine
was younger too and much less shabby and
his hair was thicker and darker he
looked happy to be back in this familiar
Place scene of so many adolescent
wanderings in the case of Voldemort
however he wasn't so lucky Harry turned
slowly on the spot and his surroundings
seemed to invent themselves before his
eyes he had spotted the thing that was
making the noises it had the form of a
small naked child curled on the ground
its skin raw and rough played looking
and it lays shuddering under a seat
where it had been left unwanted starved
out of sight struggling for breath
though many interpreted the child on the
floor of King's cross to be
representative of the Soul fragment
expelled from Harry's body
it turns out it was actually
representative of the current state of
Voldemort's Soul what exactly was the
mutilated baby-like creature Harry saw
King's cross in chapter 35 of Hallows
I've been asked this a lot it is the
last piece of Soul Voldemort possesses
okay so you die and presumably your soul
vacates your physical body what happens
next as it would appear witches and
wizards actually get to choose their
fate deciding between moving on to the
afterlife or remaining in the world of
the living however there is a catch to
remaining in the Mortal realm you won't
possess any kind of physical form the
decision to return to the world of the
living can be reflected by ghosts in
Harry Potter who make the choice to
return to the Mortal plane usually due
to unfinished business however here's
the thing about remaining as a ghost you
are just a shell of your former self
kind of similar to the shades produced
to find the resurrection Stone you
aren't alive and you aren't dead which
means that you can never truly move on
it's a bit of an empty existence per
Pottermore Muggles cannot come back as
ghosts and the wisest witches and
wizards choose not to it is those with
unfinished business whether in the form
of fear guilt regrets or overt
attachment to the material world who
refuse to move on to the next Dimension
should a ghost choose to remain in the
land of the living due to this
unfinished business they should expect a
very different existence than what they
had during their mortality the existence
of a ghost is rather shunted as they are
no longer able to derive any kind of
physical pleasure nor are they capable
of learning new things the worst part of
being a ghost however is that they
Harbor resentments that they had from
their mortality for the remainder of
their existence rendering them entirely
incapable of moving past things this
sounds more and more like a bad decision
okay so some make the decision to return
but where exactly do they make this
decision limbo after being killed by
Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest Harry
found himself in a place filled with
mist that looked like King's cross
station but this place wasn't King's
cross at all it was Limbo limbo in many
religions can be described as the Border
plays Between Heaven and Hell a place
where lost souls go before moving on to
the afterlife it's a place where one is
neither dead nor alive a place that's
often perceived as a forgotten or
ignored Place many different religions
cultures view limbo differently however
one aspect of limbo is consistent across
all of them it's not somewhere that you
want to be most outline that limbo is
the place that a recently deceased
person can make a choice move on to the
afterlife or return to the world as a
ghost which is consistent with Harry
Potter
however JK Rowling also stated that
limbo was somewhere you could be trapped
if your soul was damaged JK Rowling
confirmed in an interview that because
Voldemort had destroyed his soul with
horcruxes he would be permanently stuck
there a place that interestingly enough
would have been a stark reminder of
Voldemort's formative years when he was
laughed at wool's orphanage as a baby
and with two out of the three options
for lost souls already discussed
purgatory and limbo or returning to the
world of living as a ghost all that's
left is the Final Destination the
afterlife when discussing the process of
becoming a ghost with Harry nearly
headless Nick goes on to state that very
few Wizards would choose the path he
chose implying that there is some form
of life after death an option other than
returning to the Mortal realm this is
again reinforced through the existence
of open channels of communication
between the land of the living and the
Land of the Dead namely the Veil and the
resurrection Stone in fact in the
presence of the veil which is considered
as a sort of Gateway between the land of
living and dead Luna Harry Ginny and
Neville were all entranced hearing the
voices of their deceased loved ones from
Beyond he had the strangest feeling that
there was someone standing right behind
the veil on the other side of the
archway gripping his wand very tightly
he edged around the Deus but there was
nobody there all that could be seen was
the other side of the tattered Black
Veil and via the resurrection Stone
Arrow was able to quite clearly
communicate with shades of lost loved
ones implying they do exist somewhere
the afterlife in Harry Potter is never
clearly defined but what is clear is
that it's the best place you can go upon
dying an idyllic Place akin to a state
of Nirvana here your soul lives on in
its purified state in a place with all
of the other Souls that made the same
decision to move on a place where its
subjects are released from the cycle of
death and rebirth we know that the
Wizarding World is aware of the concept
of hell as Neville Longbottom once
references it but if Voldemort's fate is
anything to go by then remaining in
limbo is likely the Wizarding World
equivalent and that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember to the well-organized
Mind death is what the next great
adventure